no importa el tiempo para obtener un
pinchazo de esperanza desde la madrugada
cientos de personas realizan
kilométricas filas para vacunarse contra
el cob y 19 en asunción paraguay que
tiene como ambición inmunizará 4.7
millones de habitantes que tengo una
satisfacción que estamos atrayendo a la
vacuna no cualquiera esté en este
momento la vacuna sudamérica nosotros
está más viviendo acá una franja grande
de la población paraguaya como de la
últimos siete días y los datos de
paraguay es una pena es un reflejo de lo
que sucede en la región toda todo el
cono sur está con altísima tasa de
incidencia y en este momento nuestro
país es el país con más muerte por
habitante del planeta
chile entró este fin de semana en
cuarentena para contener el avance de la
pandemia y aunque su jornada de
vacunación es de las más exitosas del
mundo no es garantía sus hospitales
están a tope cuando se llama es en
venezuela la batalla por la vacuna
trasciende a lo político yo exijo hoy 11
de junio de venezuela que el gobierno de
yo de vaivén cese en su bloqueo del
dinero de venezuela para las vacunas de
covas
y aunque unas 500 millones de vacunas
han sido aplicadas en américa latina' la
organización panamericana de la salud
advirtió que la lentitud de las jornadas
puede ocasionar que el virus permanezca
en la región por varios años